[Music]
where would I be without you mr. mittens
[Music]
it's not a meme it's a fact
we can't live without cats do you know
why disease famine cuteness withdrawal
and you don't have nine lives do you
think you could survive if you has no
cheeseburger
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were no more cats the
goddess of war the king of the jungle
the world's fastest creature and your
home's biggest sleeper go ahead call
your cat lazy but keep in mind you're
talking about the sixth most successful
hunting animal in the world domestic
cats kill 32 percent of their prey
compare that to the Tigers 5% kill rate
and you'll realize that Milly isn't just
a cute little cuddle monster
she's a deadly assassin cats sleep for
roughly 16 hours a day and spend the
rest of their time prowling hunting
practicing and preparing for the worst
worldwide rat infestation it's not
really something we need to worry about
I mean come on
rats taking over the world that's
impossible not in a world without cats
we humans like to give ourselves credit
for being innovative and adaptable when
it comes to solving the world's biggest
problems and yet while rats may or may
not have spread a plague that killed up
to 200 million people we still haven't
come up with a foolproof way of
controlling their numbers sure there are
rat traps and rat poisons but really
cats do most of the work killing roughly
20 billion small mammals every year so
without them we'd be sick starving and
dying fast from cuteness withdrawal you
know rats are gross but how gross put it
this way one rat carries thousands of
pathogens on just one centimeter of its
fur and any one of these pathogens could
be fatal to you but what are your
chances of getting sick well at the rate
rats reproduce the
they're stacked against you did you know
that one pair of rats can produce over
2,000 offspring per year that means that
within three years that same couple
could have over half a billion
descendants this isn't your average
infestation it's an epidemic and it's
not just rat bites that will make you
sick rat excrement can toxify the air
you breathe causing your lungs to fill
with fluid resulting in a quick death
you might evade the infirmary but not
famine there's a reason why farmers keep
barn cats and that's to prevent an
all-out assault on grain stores rats
don't just go for cheese they go for
everything grain and produce are the
staples we need and the foods rats love
without cats there's a lot of rat mouths
to feed our agricultural systems would
collapse and now with disease rampant
and food scarce humans would be forced
to scrounge for scraps kind of like rats
but humans aren't the only ones who have
to worry
rats are also responsible for 40% and
60% of all sea bird and reptile
extinctions so if we're to stand a
chance against this rapture we've got a
band together hand in paw respect your
cat and be grateful for the gifts it
leaves on your doorstep the world would
be bleak without their presence